when you when you're going through this
what what is the program they have
to
coach counsel
the sniper after they had an experience
who did you guys go talk to to calm you
down
was there anybody
no
listen it took me
on that my last tour of afghan i got
blown up
also i got um i got my helmet here i got
shot on the helmet so i got shot there
and it came out there
wow
and it knocked me out for about
20 probably 20 seconds i was clean out
and that was an ak-47 short round and
that got shot at probably a hundred
yards
um if that and it knocked me clean out
and then three weeks after that i got
blown up by an ied 30 kilo anti-tank
mine hit my vehicle which i broke both
my arms i got a
a brain injury my hips knackered
everything
and then um
i was
put back to england
and then six weeks later
they took the casts off my hands maybe
do 10 press-ups and redeployed me
back
into afghanistan
and then when my tour finished i didn't
feel right up here you know when my tour
finished
um
i did 23 years in the british army and
it took me half an hour to get kicked
out
to say goodbye
no thank you no
good service no nothing they just
just kick you out they kick you out for
what for
uh ptsd
adjustment disorder uh and also my
injuries my injuries 23 years and took
him half an hour so
how do you feel
how do in your mind how do you feel
about the the way they handled it how do
you feel about
uh the military itself is it more your
frustration is towards an individual or
the entire institution as a whole you
know where is your biggest frustration
with
just uh
how the army treat people with ptsd
um and how they go about treating it
don't get me wrong my i have a friend
now who's suffering and he's still
serving he's he's in the process of
getting discharged and um
what they've offered him the regiment
is fantastic
but when i
you know eight years ago
it was no nothing like that it was just
you get
kicked out the regiment you get palmed
off onto um like a sick regiment where
they look after all the wounded and
injured soldiers
and then from there they sort your
discharge papers out and you you're gone
you know did they give you a hundred
percent retirement is it 100
50
30 retirement on 23 years
yeah so not even 100 disability any of
that they didn't give you any of that
that's 30
it's kind of weird because in u.s they
started doing 100 this on things like
this
and they were not at one point but 30 so
what did you do after being a sniper how
do you make your money i mean on your
resume you say hey i'd like to get a job
here what are you great at i'm great at
taking people out two thousand you know
you know what do you go do do you become
a manager somewhere what is
what what job qualifies you to go and
say i'm qualified to do this job
i'm lucky i work for a company at the
moment that um
understand about ptsd and understand and
i'm probably the
third fourth person i was in the
military sort of like being discharged
and they're really good and i just work
in a factory basically i work in a
factory and that's all i do now and i
sit in my bench making parts
for um machinery
and
that's all i do and it's it's my it's
it's my numbing but it's it's a job and
i'm lucky to have a job and i'm lucky
that this company's is taking me on and
they looked after me and i appreciate
that well good for them man for doing
that you know the companies that do
things like that
uh i i spoke to a group in dallas who
were former paratrooper navy seals delta
you know all the main ones ranger all
the big ones in u.s that we have right
and
these are sharp looking guys like you
sharp guys strong guys and having a hard
time getting a job then a hard time
getting a job after their career because
what do you see on your resume you know
although some of them like a sniper i
can imagine a sniper are you a math guy
or are you somebody that's good with
numbers i'm assuming you have to be as a
sniper right because the whole thing is
math and angle yeah but since i've um
got a tbi
um
little things
that stress me i get stressed a lot
lately you know i get um
frustrated with myself because i can't
do much like i used to like um this
november i'm i'm having my hips replaced
you know so i won't be able to go into
the gym so that's more stress and more
frustration with me you know but
the the going back to the army the
army's getting much better at how
they're dealing with things the british
army and the way they're handling it
yeah
nowadays they're getting much better you
know i think they're learning by their
mistakes so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you